SPEAKER: Thank you all so
much for being here today.
This year, to
celebrate Pride, we
wanted to create spaces to have
some really meaningful dialogue
about our identities.
And we're so excited that
BGN, Black Googlers Network
and Gayglers partnered up to
bring DeRay Mckesson for you
today.
AUDIENCE: Whoo!
SPEAKER: I'm going
to read DeRay's bio.
DeRay is a protester, and he's
dedicated to ending police
and state violence, notably
through Campaign Zero
and as a civil rights
activist both at the local
and the national level.
He previously worked at
the Harlem Children's Zone
and TNTP, opened an
academic enrichment
center in West Baltimore, and
with Baltimore City Public
Schools and Minneapolis
Public Schools
is leading systemic
human capital change.
He was recently named as one of
the 50 World's Greatest Leaders
by "Fortune Magaine" and
as one of the 30 Most
Influential People on the
internet by "Time Magazine."
Please help me welcome
DeRay Mckesson.
[APPLAUSE]
DERAY MCKESSON: Appreciate it.
It's an honor to be here.
It's good to see some familiar
faces and so many new faces.
This is embarrassing
for you, Ben,
but I went to college with Ben!
I saw Ben in the hallway
and was like, oh my god!
I haven't seen Ben in forever!
So most people know that
I wear belt every day,
but I also wear my
Bowdoin-- I mean,
most people know I wear
this vest every day,
but I wear a Bowdoin
belt every single day,
which you don't see.
And Ben and I want to Bowdoin.
So if you don't know Ben, you
should meet him afterwards,
because he's great.
So I know we're going to do
a moderated conversation.
I'm most excited about
these questions, which
I've not heard, and also your
questions which are going to be
probably the freshest things.
I worry sometimes
that I tweet so much,
and I talk so much, that you've
probably heard everything
I could possibly say.
So your questions
make me most excited.
But I will say on
August 16th, 2014,
I was sitting on my
couch in Minneapolis.
I was a senior director
of human capital,
and I was looking
on Twitter to see
what's happening in Ferguson.
I was looking at TV to see
what's happening in Ferguson,
and they were not
the same stories.
And I was like, I want
to go see for myself.
And I just wanted
to go bear witness.
So I got in the car.
I drove nine hours to St. Louis.
I put on Facebook that
I am going to St. Louis.
I didn't know anybody in
the state of Missouri.
I wanted to find somebody who
knew somebody who knew somebody
whose couch I could sleep on.
Seven hours in, I
get a call in Iowa,
and there's some
rough roads in Iowa.
I got a call.
And, you know, it
was-- Google Maps.
If you work on the
Google Maps team,
Google Maps almost got me
in Iowa, let me tell you.
Because there was no
reception, so I took this call,
and then it was like
my GPS was like, wahh.
So there was a lot
of faith in Iowa.
But I got a call, and
they were like, DeRay,
we found somewhere
for you to sleep.
And that was my story.
So I showed up in the middle
of the street in St. Louis
like so many other people
in those early days.
You know, Mike got
killed the 9th.
I was there on the 16th.
The second day that
I was in St. Louis
was the first day of the
curfew-- if any of you
remember the curfew,
back in those early days.
And it was also the first
night that I got teargassed.
And it was in that
moment that I said,
I will do whatever
I can to make sure
that this is not a world
that other people have
to experience like this.
Before that, my work
was all about kids.
I was a teacher.
I opened up after
school programs.
I was the number two in human
capital in Baltimore City
Public Schools and Minneapolis.
But I had this moment
that was like, you
gotta be alive to learn.
Right?
And I've done all
this work to make
sure kids have a great
teacher every single day.
And Tamir will never know
a high school teacher.
Mike Brown will never
know a college professor.
Aiyana, Rekia, so many people.
And that changed
the world for me.
One of the things
I worry about when
I think about the
last 20-ish months,
I worry that people think
of protesters or protests
as only those of us who
stood in streets, only
those of us who put our bodies
on the line in that way.
But what I know to be true today
is that protest, at its root,
is this idea of telling
the truth in public.
We stood in streets to tell
the truth with our bodies,
that Mike should be alive,
and Rekia should be alive,
and Aiyana, that we disrupted
board meetings and commissions
to tell the truth,
that they should
be using their
power in ways that
benefited the lives
of black people
and other marginalized people.
And in that sense, there
are many ways for all of us
to tell the truth in this
work, that you are not
absolved from your
commitment to social justice
just because you have
not been in streets,
but we all have a role to play.
And that has to be how
we think about what comes
next in the movement space.
I'm excited to talk
about the questions.
I do have many worries
about where we go next,
but I'm hopeful because I
know that so many people
over the last 20 months
have done so much to make
this a nationwide conversation.
That we are talking about
race and justice and identity
in ways that we have never
talked about in public
in our generation.
And that is really powerful.
And there's a real
onus on all of us
to make sure that we turn
this into more than a moment--
that this is not just a
really cool conversation we've
been having for
the last 20 months,
but that we actually
change the world
in some demonstrable ways.
And I think that
that part of the work
is potentially less sexy
than the beginning part
of the work for some people.
But that work is really
important, that if all we do
is change the conversation,
we have not done enough.
But changing the conversation
is unbelievably hard work.
And I say that as
somebody who-- you know,
we were in the street
for 300 plus days.
I'm just one of many people who
did that across the country.
And it has been
powerful to see people
own their voices in
new and incredible ways
every single day.
DERAY MCKESSON: And I do
think that the conversation
about identity is something
that we didn't know
was going to happen
in those early days.
Like we just had no clue.
But it's been powerful to see.
I remember the first
time in St. Louis
that there was ever a
conversation about sexuality.
There was a protest.
So the police killed Mike,
and then they killed 10 people
after Mike Brown in St. Louis.
So it was like just
continuous trauma.
And they killed
VonDerrit in Shaw,
which is in St. Louis city.
And I'll never forget it.
It was like the police had
circled in this intersection,
and they were like
pepper spraying people.
It was a mess.
And this guy walks
up to the police,
and he's like, you
fucking faggots!
That's like what he
yells at the police.
Then he turns around.
This other protester looks
at him, and it's like chaos.
Right?
The whole night is chaos.
And this guy looks at me.
He was like, that
really offended me.
And the guy's like, I'm sorry.
And I was like, wow!
Look at that!
[LAUGHTER]
And it was in that
moment that I was like, I
think we'll be all right.
Like I think that we
will figure this out,
and that we will
continue to push
the boundaries of what
people have thought
community looked like.
And that moment is
something I refer to often,
because he was like, you
offended me, I was like,
oh, this is about to be bad.
[LAUGHTER]
And then he was like, I'm sorry.
And I was like, yes.
So, you know, I think
about those small moments
often, because I
think that they have
larger implications about
how we build community,
how we come together,
what that means,
and how we learn to love
each other differently.
So excited to be here.
That was just a beginning.
I'm excited for [? Rebecca ?].
She's been a great
wrangler of me
over the last couple of weeks.
And I'm most excited
for your questions.
Thank you so much, y'all.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER: So I want to start
the conversation on the point
that you made about our
different identities
or our identity categories.
At the GLAAD Gala, you had
a quote that's so beautiful.
It says, there is beautiful
complexity in our identities,
and that there is
danger in the either/or.
I know you talked about
it now, but can you
touch on intersectionality,
and why is it so important
that we continue to
have these conversations
and actually drive
them with action?
DERAY MCKESSON: Yeah, I
was somewhere recently
and somebody said, DeRay, you
are like black first or gay
first?
And I was like, well, ehh?
You know?
And in the end what I said was
that you see my blackness first
before you see
anything else, but I
like live in all
of my identities
at the same time, every moment.
And part of our
work is how do we
make sure that people are safe
living in their identities
at every moment whether
you see it or not.
Right?
And just because you don't
know doesn't mean I'm hiding.
Just because you don't know I'm
gay doesn't mean I'm not gay.
And it also doesn't mean
that I need to tell you
every two seconds about it.
But it is about how do we
make sure we do our part
to make sure that people are
safe in every part of the world
they live in.
The thing about the
either or was not
necessarily about identity
as much as it was-- I
think in some of
these places that we
are so passionate
about the work,
we take these camps, right?
We're either reformists
or revolutionaries.
We either live in
community or we don't live
in-- it becomes so [INAUDIBLE].
The camp speak
becomes so intense.
And people, I think, don't
often do the work of saying,
here's how we can actually
do both at the same time.
So you think about Congress, the
sit-in that Congress just did.
I have my concerns with it.
But overall, I support it.
And people are-- it's
like this either/or.
Either you hate the no-fly
list and you hate everything.
You know, it's like people
aren't allowing for people
to say like, I believe in
the sit-in that they did,
and I think the no-fly
list is a bad thing.
I think those are both real.
People are sort of camped
out, where either you
hate John Lewis and
the other congressmen,
or you completely
support the no-fly list.
And I think that
that isn't a fair way
to think about the world.
And I think that the way
we show up in the world
is much more complex
than this either/or,
that the both/and takes a little
more work to think through.
But I think that's the most
honest way to be in the world.
SPEAKER: I know we were
talking a little bit before
on your talk about the quiet.
So DeRay had a comment that
says, I wasn't in the closet,
I was in the quiet.
The quiet is a place
where you're not
supposed to make noise.
Can you tell us more about
the quiet and anything,
like the pressures that
you might have felt,
or that we feel about
staying in the quiet?
DERAY MCKESSON:
Yeah, I got worried
about people
talking-- like I don't
think I was in the closet.
I just think I wasn't
talking about being
gay, which wasn't me hiding.
The closet, to me, is
this idea that I'm hiding,
and I don't want people to know,
and I'm putting something away.
And that wasn't how I
thought about it myself,
but I didn't have the language
to think about it differently.
So I was like, you know, I
think I'm in the quiet, right?
Just because you didn't know
doesn't mean that I was hiding.
And it was like this image
of the library as a place
where people are supposed
to be quiet because quiet
is how you learn, right?
Quiet is the best way
to access information.
It is what keeps you
safe, in a certain sense.
But what we know about
libraries is that people
whisper all the time.
And it is that
collective whisper
that actually makes noise.
And it is the
whispers that I think
we need to honor in many ways.
I think the movement-- it
was a lot of whispers, right?
It was people all
across the country,
definitely all across
St. Louis, saying,
we think something is wrong.
We don't know what
to do, and we don't
know who believes with us,
but we think something is up.
The corollary I see between
identity and the movement
was all these people
coming together saying,
I think we want to
talk about something.
It's a little quiet right
here, but let us come together
and make a louder noise.
When I think about identity,
I do think a lot of people
are in the quiet.
And then our part as
organizers is, how do we
help people feel comfortable
moving out of that quiet space
and not shaming people
for being in the quiet?
But taking as our responsibility
that some people feel
like that is the only
way they can be safe
or that is the most honest
way that they can be
who they are and also be safe.
I remember, you know, growing
up in Baltimore and people--
like I remember the sting
of being called a faggot.
I remember that as a kid.
And there are some
places as a kid
that I made a choice
whether I was going
to talk about identity a
certain way, because I just
didn't want to be traumatized
like that anymore.
And how do we
build a world where
people can be who they
are in the way they want
to be that is safe every time?
You think about
that when we think
about the bathrooms, right?
Like when I was in the
Breakfast Club with Charlemagne,
and Charlemagne, he said
some problematic things
about a whole host of issues.
But we talked about the bathroom
bill in the trans community.
And I'm like, Charlemagne,
what do you do in the bathroom.
Like what are you
doing in the bathroom?
When I go to the bathroom,
I'm like going in, going
to the bathroom, coming out.
I'm not having a party.
I'm not passing out
business cards, right?
Like what is--
People should be able to--
what you do in the bathroom,
people should be able
[? to be safe ?] doing that,
right?
And he's like, I
mean, I guess, DeRay.
And I'm like, yeah!
So how do we help
people complicate
the way we think about identity
and especially complicate
the way we think about
what safety means?
SPEAKER: Is there
an added stigma
to being queer in black
and brown communities?
DERAY MCKESSON: You know, I
worry about-- it in my head,
I think about this
in the same way
that I think about
black on black violence.
I don't want to
stigmatize blackness
as being like more homophobic
than anything else.
I am black, and there
are definitely a lot
of black homophobic people.
That is real.
I believe that there
are the same number
of homophobic people
in all communities.
I have a different proximities
to black homophobic people,
because I grew up
around black people.
So I do think there is
something about the way
that masculinity
functions, especially
in marginalized communities
as a signifier of power
when you don't have power.
What it means to be marginalized
is that you are on the margins,
right?
And on the margins, you
are unseen and unheard.
And I think that
there are moments
when you can perform a certain
way to be heard and seen
in a way that's acceptable.
And I think
masculinity functions
like that, that
people can perform
a way to sort of mask
some of the things
that they struggle with about
being marginalized in general.
And I think that that encourages
a very subtle, though still
insidious form of
homophobia that is, I think,
particular because
of its manifestations
in marginalized communities,
but not unique in impact.
SPEAKER: When you talk about on
these margins, the people who
are marginalized and from
different angles because
of their identity, what
are some of the needs
that someone at these
intersections has?
DERAY MCKESSON: When I think
about the intersectionality--
I've started to talk about my
worries more publicly, just
because I want everybody
to push forward.
But what I worry about
with intersectionality
is that people really only
care about their intersection,
right?
That people are like,
intersectionality!
But here's where I stand.
And you're like, eh?
[LAUGHTER]
I don't know.
I think, at the simplest
level, it's this understanding
that we have complex identities,
and we are all of them
at the same time,
and that we, again,
build a world where
people get to do that.
And it is true
that people should
be able to speak for
their own, and they
should be able to talk
about their experience
in a way that is authentic,
to help people understand.
I'm an ally to the
trans community.
There are so many things
that I need to learn,
and I'm not the best spokesman.
I definitely try to be the
best ally that I can be,
which means that I have to
listen more than I talk, right?
And I think that is
a key part of what
it means to stand
at the intersection,
especially intersections
that are not ones you claim.
But it is also about making
sure that you actually
believe in everybody's
intersections
and not just your own.
And I think that
as the conversation
has become more and more
public that people really
are camping out in
the spaces that they
feel the most comfortable.
And I get it in the
sense that like,
I try to be a really good ally.
I think I have a big platform.
I want to push these messages.
I have to own, though, that
there are so many identities
that I don't know
intimately, that I'm still
learning and growing.
And we have to
continue that mindset
as we push forward in
the work, because I think
that is like the most honest.
I think that's the most
impactful and the most true.
SPEAKER: Awesome.
I want to shift
gears a little bit.
You know, you talked about how
you got involved with the Black
Lives Matter movement.
But I want to hear more
about the great work
that you're doing
with Campaign Zero,
and if you could just give
us some background on how
that got started.
DERAY MCKESSON: So when I
think about the movement,
I think about four phases.
The first was like--
the first nine months,
we were helping people
understand that there was
a crisis across the country.
So if you remember like
August 2014, people were like,
St. Louis is screwed up.
Ferguson is screwed up.
People were not like,
America has a problem.
They were like, the police
in St. Louis are crazy.
And the police in St.
Louis are definitely crazy,
so that was true.
But it was not only the
police in St. Louis.
So it took until the death of
Sandra Bland, Walter Scott,
Freddie Gray for people
to be like, OK, I
think there's like a
crisis across the country.
And it's like, OK.
And the second phase
of the work, I think,
is about helping people
understand and appreciate
that there are real
solutions out there.
And that's where
Campaign Zero came in.
So Campaign Zero is
modeled on this idea
that we can live in
a world where there
are zero deaths by police.
In 2016 alone, there have
been nearly three people
killed by the police every day.
In 2015, the police
killed somebody every day
but 18 days in all states.
Right?
And we just didn't
know-- I didn't
know that was happening
before Mike Brown got killed.
And we wanted to think about
what are the real policy
solutions that we can put
forward to structurally end
police violence.
We believe that we can
change structures and systems
in ways that change culture.
That is a core belief.
So it's everything
from the things
you've heard about--
select body cameras,
independent investigators--
to some stuff
that we did for the first time.
So we created the
first public database
of police union contracts.
Some Googlers helped
us out with that.
We created the first
public database
of use of force policies
around the country.
And what we've come to believe
is that the police are actually
hiding in plain sight.
So the Freddie Gray
verdict came down today.
This officer was acquitted.
And what I said to the newspaper
is like, this is disappointing,
but it is not surprising given
that we have a shadow justice
system for the police
that will protect
their behaviors at all costs.
And what we're saying
is that the things
that actually protect the
police are public documents.
So you look at the
police union contracts--
I mean, in cities
across the country,
police can only be interrogated
for 30 minutes, hour chunks.
And then they get a
legally obligated bathroom
break, phone calls, meals--
stuff that private citizens
never get.
Or you look at some of
the more insidious things.
So there are clauses
around the country that
will say like, the
police chief is
the final arbiter of discipline,
which most people are
like, that make sense because
it's the police chief, right?
So you're like, that's
a harmless clause.
It is that clause that
prevents civilian oversight
boards from having any power.
And the police have just
been amazing negotiators
in cities across the country,
putting this language
like so deeply embedded
that looks innocuous
but has huge consequences on
how we hold people accountable.
So we've been trying to lift
that work up and expose that.
And then the use
of force policies,
in cities across the country,
it is still OK to hogtie people.
Like Baltimore, you can still
hogtie and chokehold people.
It's not against policy.
It's not against the law.
It is totally acceptable.
And that's wild to us, right?
We don't think that makes sense.
So we would say the
stuff that we're pushing
for is not very controversial.
We think this is
really common sense.
The police have done
an incredible job
of systematizing it.
So you think about
places like LA.
The protections for the
police union contract
are in the charter
of the city itself.
So undoing it becomes this
crazy organizing battle.
And there is some
disagreement about some stuff
about Campaign Zero race.
So we come out in
support of body cameras.
There are a lot of organizers
around the country who
don't believe in body
cameras for reasons that
make complete sense, this
idea that if you believe
in community policing, which
is this notion that the police
should be in community.
We think that that is a really
race-based way of thinking
about the police, that if you
put police in the Upper West
Side, and they were high-fiving
white kids as they got off
the bus and as kids
were playing basketball,
people would lose their minds.
But in black communities, it's
like the police should just
be everywhere, right?
They should be there
when you get off the bus.
They should be on the corner.
So we worry about that
with community policing.
But if you believe in community
policing and body cameras,
you might create like a second
surveillance state, right?
If the police are ever present,
they have cameras on them,
they could amass this
wild batch of footage that
could be used against
people for a host of things,
especially because,
for most crimes
the statute of limitations
it's pretty long, right?
So you like hit
somebody on the cheek,
three months later you're
arrested for assault.
And we've seen the
police, even in St. Louis,
do things like that.
They'll take footage of
somebody throwing something.
Four weeks later,
they arrest you.
So we worry about those things.
We believe, though,
that there are
structures that you can
put in place to hold
people accountable.
The White House-- Megan,
who is the Chief Technology
Officer in the country, they're
doing some really interesting
things around body cameras.
One of them is
looking at the audio
to see if we can use the audio
as a predictor of aggression
in officers, to
identify officers
who are more likely
to abuse people
before there's actually trauma.
Right now, the video
is all post-trauma.
It's like, you kill somebody,
we look at the video.
But could we use the audio in a
way that's really interesting?
And there's another partner
with the White House
that's looking at, can
we create a program
to trigger the
parts of the video
that a human eye should
look at and then delete
everything else, so the
government is just not
amassing footage
on people, which
we think is like an
interesting thing, too.
So we love Campaign Zero,
met with Obama about it--
and Valerie Jarrett, and
Bernie, and Hillary, and Loretta
Lynch-- to talk
about how we actually
make these things real.
The reality, though, is
that most of the changes
happen at the local level.
At the federal
level, we're working
with the domestic-- Cecilia,
who runs the Domestic Policy
Council around the FBI.
If an FBI agent kills you
today, you're screwed.
Not only because you'll
be dead, but because there
is almost no way
that any activist can
hold them accountable.
They don't release
the names, there's
nothing-- we don't know
anything about them.
And what people
often don't realize
is that if you've heard any
number about police killings
at all, it is all from
newspaper clippings.
That is the source of truth.
That is the most robust
status that we have.
And we think that we've
actually been under-reporting.
That if you get
killed in America
and our newspaper
does not pick it up,
you are not in the data set.
You literally are--
you don't exist.
And that is wild, and that has
huge consequences for how we
think about demographic data.
So there are some
places in Texas
where the data looks like
white people are being
killed disproportionately.
We think that they are
Latino, but they're
being miscoded because
it's newspaper clippings.
So we are working with people
to do some backend cleansing.
But that's even like the
"Washington Post" database,
the "Guardian's"
database, like all of it
is newspaper clippings.
If you get killed
in America, it's
not picked up by a newspaper,
you are not in the data set.
And that is wild.
SPEAKER: You brought
up a point about-- we
think about cops hanging
out, playing basketball
in neighborhoods.
If that is not what's
providing safety,
then how can we change
the conversation
about what safety really means?
DERAY MCKESSON: Yeah--
and I'm not against cops
potentially playing basketball.
[LAUGHTER]
But there is a
notion of policing
that is like, they
should be ever present.
And then basketball becomes like
a proxy for the ever presence,
right?
It doesn't become a way
to build community or as
a part of a larger strategy
about government and community
building.
It's like, well, the police
should be here anyway.
They should pick
up a basketball.
You're like, OK.
I think that what's
real is that we
know the safety
of our communities
is not predicated on
the presence of police.
That if I asked you where
you feel the most safe,
it's probably not in
a room full of police.
It's probably in a
room where there's
family, where there's friends,
where people love you,
where there's food and shelter.
That's what safety means.
And then the question
for us becomes, how
do you scale that for people?
How do you make that
something that everybody
can be a part of?
When we think about the police,
people often think about them
in three buckets.
The first is crime prevention.
And crime prevention really
isn't police work, right?
That's like schools,
families, jobs.
The second is about
the response to crime.
And the response to crime
is more of police work.
But we know that one in four
people killed by the police
are people who have
mental health trauma.
And the response to all trauma
can't be somebody with a gun.
So you think about--
you know, I've
talked to people who called for
help when their friend might
threaten to commit suicide.
And like somebody with
a gun isn't probably
the best responder
in that situation.
So we have to start
thinking about how
do we not have a police
first response to all trauma.
And then the third bucket
is around solving crime.
And that is more police
work than not police work.
But that can't happen
when there's not
trust and accountability.
And the trust and
accountability doesn't
come when the police get
off on every single thing
that they do.
That's why people won't call.
That's why people don't
give them tips, right?
That doesn't work
when you're like,
well, they're going
to beat up my cousin,
or they beat up somebody I know.
That doesn't work.
SPEAKER: So at Google, we love
data and measuring success
with numbers.
You're tackling issues that are
so just large and important.
When you go home, how do
you measure whether or not
you're successful, your
campaigns are successful?
And is there an end point?
At what point do we say,
check, we did our job?
DERAY MCKESSON: Yeah.
So I'm mindful about
a couple things.
One is that the
movement is young,
that we won't undo 400 years of
oppression in 400 days, right?
That is not real.
I'm also mindful
that so much of this
is about lifting
data sets and stories
and making them as
public as possible.
So at Campaign Zero, we
have these huge data sets.
And we're about to
launch a new way
to look at police
union contracts that
is a little easier
for people who
are about to launch a
new project around use
of force policies and laws.
And we've been working with
a lot of people in tech.
A lot of Googlers have been a
part of our Slack group about,
how do we actually just
make this simpler for people
to access and understand?
Because we believe that the
truth is so damning that
it should radicalize people.
But we have to get
the truth to people.
How do we do that?
In terms of what
success looks like,
I think that one
real part of it is
changing the conversation,
which I think
we did and continue to do.
And then the next part
is like, how do we
continue to organize and build
power and coalitions as we
move forward?
I believe two things.
One is that there
are more people that
want to do the work
than know what to do
and there are more
people that want
to do the work than
want to be members.
I think we're in
this unique moment
where people have this
aversion to membership.
Like they want to do good work.
If you told them like,
do these three things,
they're like, yes.
If you say, like, will
you be a member of this?
They're like, eh, no.
[LAUGHTER]
Which doesn't mean
there's not a role
for membership-based
organizations.
I think there is.
I think there will always be.
I think there's also a challenge
and a role for organizers
to think about how to
mobilize and activate people
with whom you share the
same values and beliefs
but don't want to be members.
My belief about
that, my hypothesis,
is that there is a
generation of us who grew up
being members of everything.
You were a member
of this and this.
you still carry a little
bit of that around.
So you're a little gun shy.
Or you just don't want to sit
in the basement of a whatever
every Wednesday, right?
That just isn't how you think
about being in the world today.
But if somebody said, will
you do these three things,
you would totally do them.
And we're trying
to figure out how
to continue to mobilize people
around those sort of issues.
That we don't care if
you're a member or not,
as long as you do the work.
And how do we do that?
And how do we
demystify organizing?
I think that there are some
people who have organized
for 30 years and da, da, da.
You know, I grew up in
Baltimore as an organizer in '99
and when I was a teenager.
So I'm one of the people
who organized before.
But I do think that there are
people in the movement space
that sort of make
organizing out to be
this mythical thing, right?
You've got to call the
ancestors and get a conversation
with them.
You've got to read 15 books.
And I think organizing at its
root is this idea of like,
I believe the work
can be better.
Here's how.
Let me find other people
who believe that with me.
Like that is what organizing is.
That's how it starts.
And that's how I think
about measuring it now.
I think that at
some point we will
need to be honest about whether
police violence is decreasing
or not.
So once we actually
institutionalize change,
if there is no change
in the outcomes,
then we haven't done it right.
And I think the third
phase of the work
is about
institutionalizing change.
So we change the
conversation, we
help people believe
in solutions,
we institutionalize the change.
And the fourth bucket is
around protecting the change
once we make it.
So you think about
the Voting Rights Act,
as a great example
of the protect phase,
wasn't done well.
That like the rollbacks happened
in a really intense way.
They got incredible traction
with the Voting Rights Act,
and now it's been
repealed a little bit.
So how do we put these changes
in and then actually make sure
that they are livable things
that we see the fruit of?
SPEAKER: So I want to
change topics a little bit.
There was a really
interesting article
that came out last year on
"People Magazine" entitled
"Dear Black Men, You Are
Not Pro-black if You Are Not
Pro Black Women."
Do you see this?
Is that something
is present-- like
do you see the erasure of women
in black and brown communities?
And how could we address that?
DERAY MCKESSON: Yeah.
And I think erasure often
manifests in two ways.
One is that either our
stories are never told
or they're told by
everybody but us.
And what's been powerful
about this moment
is that everybody gets
to be a storyteller.
So I think about so
many incredible women
of color who are leading,
who are organizing,
who are telling
their own stories
and not waiting for
somebody-- they don't have
to wait for somebody
else to tell their story,
because there's
not a barrier there
in terms of who gets to
be storytellers anymore.
I think that's really powerful.
I think that there
is so much more work
to be done around
sexism in that space,
and I do think that it is better
and hard that we are having all
these conversations in public.
I think that people are learning
from these conversations
about sexism and misogyny
because they essentially
get to participate
as viewers first.
And I think that that is
easier for some people
before they step in.
I know a lot of
people who are worried
about saying the wrong thing.
But they are well-intentioned,
but the way they approach it,
you're like, that was not it.
But because of social media,
it has really opened up
space for them to like watch.
They can participate
by viewing first,
and then they can
sort of dive in.
I think that's really powerful.
But I do think the movement
is important in the sense
that there are men and women
working together-- women
leading in new ways, and
being present and visible,
and not having to be in
the background in the way
that they might have
been in the past.
And the people of complex
identities around sexuality
get to be present
in a way, and be
open about those
identities in ways
that they couldn't be before.
SPEAKER: Something that
is personally really sad
to me is we live in a country
where one in five women
will be sexually assaulted.
And the average life expectancy
of a black trans woman
is 35 years.
You've brought some really
challenging things to light,
and you've created a platform
where we can successfully
highlight the way
that our society has
failed these communities.
What advice can you give
us to create platforms
where we can continue
to address the issues?
DERAY MCKESSON: Yeah,
I think that-- so I'm
a Twitter evangelist.
I love Twitter.
Twitter's great.
Twitter.
I know you work at Google.
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER: Do you post on G+ ever?
DERAY MCKESSON: Huh?
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER: Do you
have a G+ account?
[LAUGHTER]
We've got to get you a G+.
DERAY MCKESSON: Awkward,
awkward, awkward.
I search all day long.
[LAUGHTER]
I say that because I do
think that storytelling is
one of our most powerful tools.
And at the root of
every story is an idea,
and ideas matter because
they inform the way
we think about the world.
And the way we think
about the world
is the way we act in the world.
And when I think about
the trans community--
when I think about what is
the next part of the work,
it's like, how do we tell these
complex stories in ways that
are simpler for people
and allow them to think
about things they can do?
So we are about to
work on a project that
is going to catalog all the
laws that have been introduced,
that are damaging to
the trans community,
and put them in a
really cool space
and help people see
so that we can tell
this story about-- like the
people we're fighting against
are actually really
organized, right?
There's something common
about all these pieces
of legislation.
And then here is actually
how you can combat it.
Here are talking points.
Here's how we equip you,
in a very visceral way,
with things to do.
Having been so close to the
work over the last 20 months,
I think that sometimes
that people on the fringe,
like the most insider of us, we
start to think that everybody
thinks the way we do, or
everybody sort of sees
the world the way
we do, or everybody,
like, obviously they
know that talking point,
and they obviously
know it's wrong.
And I will never forget
the first nine months
of the movement where
there were black people who
were like, I don't think
the police are crazy.
And we're like, the police
literally just killed him.
And they're like, but that
wasn't my neighborhood.
And you're like, what?
So it took us mobilizing our
own community a long time
to help people actually believe
that this was close to them.
And I think that with
the work around identity,
we can't take for granted that
there are people who we love
and who love us who still
don't get it but want to.
And then it's like,
how do we equip
them to get it on
their own and to get it
with more data and information?
And I think about some of
the things about identity,
we haven't-- there's just not
a public space yet to learn
the right things to say.
I think about "love is
love" as a great example.
So when Orlando
happened, people offered
really interesting
push-back on love is love.
And what they were saying is
that like, yes, love is love,
but my identity--
like my sexuality
is not just based on whether
I'm in a relationship or not,
which I think is an interesting
way to think about it.
And that language,
I don't know if I
would have been exposed
to that if I just hadn't
been on Twitter that day.
How do we help
people be in places
or go places to like
complicate the way they
think about the world so they
can be better in the world.
Because I think that
is-- you're like, yes,
"love is love" sort of
reinforces this idea that you
are gay as long as you like
visibly love somebody else
who is also same gender.
How do we say that
that is a part of it,
but that is-- I'm gay whether
I'm single or not, right?
And I think that we have to do
more of that storytelling work
and be really
intentional about it.
And I think that sometimes we
take for granted that part.
We're like, we're just
going to put the data out,
and we're going to do da, da.
And we miss the simple
truths that people
can repeat over and over.
And "love is love" is a
great simple truth, right?
It's simple, repeated
over and over.
It's like, how do
we complicate those,
and how do we create
new ones that people
can do that really push
the work, you know?
SPEAKER: I feel like
sometimes I can physically
see people getting uncomfortable
when we talk about race.
Why are we so uncomfortable
having these conversations?
DERAY MCKESSON: I
think some of it
is there's still
a lot of trauma,
and people haven't dealt
with their own trauma, which
is no indictment of them.
Because you shouldn't live
in a world where you were
traumatized.
Some of it, too,
is that-- there are
a lot of people who are
afraid of the outcome, right?
They think that there's going
be a lot of loss that comes.
So you think about the
privileging of whiteness.
I know white people
who totally get
white privilege, who
are like, it is bad,
and don't want it to end.
Like they want to
dismantle white privilege
but can't imagine
a world without it.
And I think that is real.
And it's like, how do we have a
public conversation about what
that looks like?
You will not have the
privilege once it's gone.
Right?
That is a condition of the
end of white privilege.
And I think there are people
who conceptually don't get that
yet.
They're like, yeah, that's bad!
And you're like, you're
not going to have it,
and they're like, no!
And you're like, no, no.
[LAUGHTER]
So how do we talk about that?
And then I think that there
is a real thing-- you know,
I've come to understand
that my role is not always
to be the person giving lectures
to people about ending racism,
right?
That some of this
work is about asking--
being the person sitting
with people asking them
the question.
That if I'm trying to get
you to change your mind,
and I know you approach it
from a problematic space--
like me lecturing
you for 20 minutes
probably isn't going to do that.
But if I say to you, like,
should Freddie Gray be dead?
And we start from there,
like a real honest space,
and then you say something,
and then I respond,
that actually is probably
better at converting you
than me being like,
I can't believe
you think that Freddie
Gray killed himself
and six people watched him.
You know?
You enter the conversation
not believing that, right?
So me yelling at you about
it isn't going to do that.
And I think that
there's something
that we do as much as
marginalized people who
live this every
day, that we hear
people say problematic
things, and we're
like, argh, which makes
sense to me, because it
is emotional and real.
I think that, in terms
of converting people,
sometimes our approach
can be like the really
thoughtful, incisive question
that puts the onus back
on them.
They actually have
to do the work.
Because sometimes we get so
riled up doing all the work,
we're over-processing things.
And they walk away
still believing
the same thing, totally chill.
You're worked up.
You need a nap!
You're like, I'm done today!
And they actually haven't
thought anything differently.
And I think that that's real.
And also white people
have to figure out
how to organize white people
and challenge white people.
So think about there
are white people who
are going to say and do things
about race around each other
that they would
never do around me,
which is probably
better for both of us.
But it is about, how do we get
white people in those spaces
to hold other white
people accountable
and truly push them to
think about the stories
that they allow other people to
tell, the truth that they allow
other people to
disseminate over and over,
and then how they use
their resources and skills
and abilities in this work.
You know, I met a lot of
people, and we rarely, if ever,
ask people for money.
And we met a lot of
really interesting people.
We always ask people for
their time and talent.
Because that is a conversation
about resources, right?
If I'm in a room
with a billionaire,
I don't need a gazillion--
if money alone could fix it,
we would have fixed it.
I need to figure out how we
can use your time and talent
to create new something, right?
And if you-- who
can I pick on that
won't be-- so I think about
like there's some people,
it's like, skip the street.
We don't need you in the street.
Don't come to the street.
But you calling
the governor means
something very different than
me calling the governor, right?
And how do we be really
clear with people
about how you use your
access and privilege in ways
that change people's
lives for the better?
SPEAKER: So with
that point, there's
people here that have
incredible skills
and have a lot of access, and
we have a lot of privilege.
How do we identify what
to do with that access
to really drive social
and economic change?
DERAY MCKESSON: I think that--
so there are a couple things.
One is you can join people who
have already made a commitment
to doing the work, right?
I'm sensitive, though, that
you also-- you probably
have an idea of that cool
thing that should exist,
that you're like,
I think it exists,
but I don't want to create
it, because it might exist.
Like most of us have those ideas
when we think about this work.
And you can actually
start that right now.
And you don't need
permission to do it.
You don't need a huge
platform to do it.
I think about some
of the cool-- Sam,
who built Mapping
Police Violence, which
is one of the projects
in Campaign Zero.
Sam lived in San Francisco.
He randomly tweeted
me one day and was
like, DeRay, I want
to do something.
I DM'd him back my phone
number, and we had a good call.
He made this website.
We pushed it out to everybody,
and it was like a thing,
you know?
And now Sam's a
part of our team.
But he was somebody
who was like, I
think we should map police
violence in a different way.
And I was like, build
it, and we'll totally
help people see it.
I think there are
a lot of-- I think
there's this myth that people
have to join these existing
structures or da da da da.
And if you want to,
you should, right?
Because there are a lot of
great organizations out there.
But I think about the
movement as a space,
that no organization that
got us together in Ferguson.
Right?
This infrastructure
emerged, and there's
a difference between
organizations
and infrastructure.
The infrastructure is there.
I was a tweeter.
There were people who
were live streamers.
There was a bail fund.
Like we all worked
together, and there
was like some sort of unwritten
rules about how we'd interact.
But there was no
like organization
that we had to join to
be in the movement space.
And I think now
people sort of feel
like they got to join
something to be a part of it.
But you probably already
know that really cool thing
that should exist.
I think about, somebody
used Twilio last week
to make a phone number
that if people dialed it--
you dial the phone number,
you put in your zip code,
and it automatically
called your two senators
and representatives
around gun control.
Really simple.
It would have taken me
like 10 years to make.
Took this guy like 10 seconds.
He made it.
He had no platform.
We found out about it because
we know some people at Twilio.
We blasted it out to
like all these people.
And like Russell Simmons,
he put it in his networks.
We pushed it out
really wide and far.
And he just made it on
his own time, right?
Like I don't know
him, but we totally
made that thing a bigger
thing than it was on its own.
And he didn't need
to join anybody.
He just thought it was
the right thing to do.
And now we love Twilio.
We're like, Twily everything!
But yeah, so if
you want to do some
of the stuff we're doing, like
we have a Slack group of just
tech people, people who
are committed to building
new platforms that help
people think about the problem
differently, and
most importantly,
think about the
solutions differently.
Because I worry in
the movement space
that it's easier to talk
about the problems than it
is the solutions.
That like there's this
addiction to being like,
the world is bad.
And it's like, got
it, got it, got it.
And it's like, what do we do?
People are like, I don't know!
Well, that's not helpful.
So we'd much rather
at least keep
failing around the
solutions than only
talking about the problems.
And there's an easy way
to be a part of our team
but, again, you can
be a part of-- you
being in the work will
make you better at this.
And I know a lot of people
in the tech community
specifically who have
joined and been in spaces,
and they might be quiet
in them, but they go home
and they're like, oh my god,
I heard a person say that.
We should totally
think about this.
And it's like, yes!
That's often how
this work starts.
And I worry sometimes
that there's
this myth that like-- I don't
know, again, you get this phone
call from the ancestors.
It's like, please do this today.
And that's not what happens.
SPEAKER: So what
about #activism?
Is it better that we're
talking about the problem?
You say we like to talk
about problem, solution.
Is #activism helping?
Or is it just like
procrastinating people
actually making a change?
DERAY MCKESSON: Yeah, I think
that I'll never criticize
people for telling the truth.
And I think that truth
telling is such a hard thing,
especially for people of
color and marginalized people.
And if Twitter is like the
space that you tell the truth,
then I'm all about it.
Truth telling has been
such a difficult thing,
has been a thing that this
country has prohibited
black people from organizing
around and doing it
that I will always honor
the fact that people use
digital spaces to tell the
truth in. [? That is ?] real,
knowing that that
is, again, not always
the end of the work, right?
That that is often the
beginning of the work.
But that has a role to play.
And if it were not for Twitter
in St. Louis in August 2014,
Missouri would have convinced
you that we didn't exist.
You know?
They literally would
have been like,
those people aren't there!
And it was like, that is crazy!
So when you think
about Baltimore,
what makes Baltimore
stand out is not only
the circumstances of
Freddie's death and sort
of Baltimore's proximity to
DC and all this other stuff.
It is that it was the
first big city in protest
that you saw aerial footage of.
Because you didn't see
any of that in St. Louis.
Because they put a no-fly
zone on like August 11.
They got the game down.
So if it wasn't for social
media, like literally
you wouldn't have seen it.
I get frustrated now
talking about the protests,
because people
think that we like
marched in solidarity
with the '60s.
And we were like
marching because that was
what we thought protest was.
It was illegal to stand still
in August of 2014 in St. Louis,
right?
We marched because we literally
could not stand still.
It was called the
five-second rule.
And it was like, you can't
stand still, and you can't pace,
and you can't return
to the same spot.
So you couldn't
like walk down there
and then come back to this spot.
It was wild, you know?
And that was the
world we lived in.
And you didn't necessarily see
all of that on TV and stuff
because they had put such
an effective blackout
on the media.
But again, the fact
that you saw anything
was because we had social media.
And I'll never criticize
social media for that.
I do think that this
has to be a combination
of the online and offline,
that that has to be real.
It is always funny
to me that people
take to Twitter to talk about
how much Twitter doesn't
matter.
And you're like, if it didn't
matter, why are you posting?
But yeah, no, so
I think that most
of the critiques that people
offer about social media
are disingenuous, or
it's people who loved it
when they had a big platform.
And now that people
aren't listening to them,
they're like, oh my
god, Twitter's awful.
And you're like, meh.
SPEAKER: Well.
I'd love to open up the floor.
If anyone has questions,
we have a mic over here.
We'd love to hear your thoughts.
AUDIENCE: I have a question
as a black straight male,
like how you said about
white people should organize
other white people
about issues, how can I
organize other black males?
Because there was like
an issue at our school
where some people-- like some of
the black [INAUDIBLE] students
[? that have ?] woke were
unaware of the sexism
and homophobia they
projected on the people
they're trying to fight for.
They still would say some
of the very sexist things
behind in our group meetings
and stuff like that.
So how can I have it where I
can have an open conversation
with them and tell them,
beware of their microagression
stuff they have?
Because some of
them are just like,
I can't be sexist
and homophobic.
Or like, they think they
don't have certain privileges,
because they don't think what's
happening in America with them
as a black male,
they don't think
they have any
privileges of being
a straight male in America.
So how can I have the open
discussion or activities
to make them aware of
these sort of things
and make them more inclusive
of the other people
we're supposed to
represent and help out?
DERAY MCKESSON: That's real.
I'm mindful that we
aren't born woke.
Something wakes us up.
And there's like a real
difference between being
woke and staying woke.
And I think about myself.
There are people who are
like, I like you DeRay!
And they hate gay people, right?
But they're like, I like you!
And you're like,
eh, I don't know.
I don't know [INAUDIBLE].
[LAUGHTER]
A couple things.
One is that this work
is often slow for people
to own their growth areas around
these sort of deep things,
right?
I also think that some of
the most effective ways
to change individual
people's hearts and mind
is in private
sometimes, and then
using examples that are
not necessarily about them,
that they don't
realize are about them,
but that are about them.
So I think about people who say
some really problematic stuff.
And if I say to them,
you just said that thing
that is really
crazy, then we'd be
fighting for the next whatever.
But if I say to
them, I can't believe
that person said that, which
is really what they just said.
And then we use that as
a launching pad and then
sort of, at the end, get back
to like, you said that, too,
and that was really problematic.
I think that people need
to process this stuff.
And I say that because I've
seen people try and beat people
over the head about it.
Like you are homophobic,
and da, da, da,
which I think there's a
place for sometimes, right?
Because some people
just say wild things,
and you've got to
check it real quick.
But there are some people
who are trying but need
a different space to try.
I know a lot of straight men
who are really transphobic
and don't know it.
They think they are
standing in solidarity
with the trans community
but are super problematic.
And it's like,
how do we actually
have those conversations
with people
like in really honest, closed
spaces that allow them to grow?
I think about my conversation
with Charlemagne.
Charlemagne said some
really problematic things
about the trans community.
But if I had gone
in being like, you
said this, like I don't
think we would have
had a productive conversation.
As opposed to like,
Charlemagne, let's
just talk about
this a little bit.
And he moved much further
than he had before publicly
and when we talked afterwards.
And I think that that has
to be some of how we do it.
But it is important to have
people see that they have
done some of this too, right?
That you said "faggot"
and that was really--
me and Azealia Banks
had that back and forth
on Twitter about her
saying "faggot," right?
And she was like,
DeRay, da, da, da.
And she texted me being
like, da, da, da, da.
And then last week,
she's like, I will never
say "faggot" again.
It's like, oh, OK,
thanks Azealia.
This took a long time coming.
But it was about how
do I say like that
is just problematic, right?
And we can talk about it, but
I want to say to you publicly,
this is not OK.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
DERAY MCKESSON: Yep.
AUDIENCE: I'm Marnie.
I identify as transgender and
have done training sessions
here at Google called
[? Trans at ?] Google.
And some of it is
definitely dumbed down.
Like it's kind of a 101.
And there's a really interesting
conversation happening
within the trans Google
community about, you know,
how much of this is
our responsibility
and why are we having to
justify our existence?
And I'm kind of the
mind, well, there
are people out there who aren't
malicious, and we need allies.
That's important.
But I think a part
of me is like, oh,
is this just
internalized transphobia,
that that's the reason I'm out
here justifying my identity?
And so I guess I was wondering
what your thoughts are,
and I think that's a debate
in a lot of different places.
DERAY MCKESSON: Yeah.
That's real.
That's a real question.
I think about, there are
a lot of black people
who are like, it's not my
work to teach white people
about blackness, right?
They're like, go read.
There are a lot of
things out there.
I think the reality is that it
is not everybody's work, right?
That there are some
people who are like,
this is not how I
plan to show up.
This is not what I think
it means to organize,
and that is real, and
we should honor that.
We shouldn't force people to
teach people other things.
The other thing,
though, is that is
how some people think
about their work,
and that is also real.
And we should allow
them to do that.
And I would rather me help
you think through something
than you like read some crazy
thing from some crazy person,
and then you think
that that is the truth,
and then we're fighting.
So I am one of the
people, like you,
who is like, I think that
we can talk about it.
I don't think that it is
internalized anything,
but I do think that
we have to always
be mindful of our
motivations in it.
There are some people
who are teaching
because they want the validation
from that crowd, right?
There are some people who are
teaching to answer questions
and to be somebody
who helps people think
about a different experience.
And I'm somebody who
still is learning
about the trans community,
for instance, right?
And if people wouldn't talk
to me about their experience,
I wouldn't know.
And I would think I'm
a really good ally,
and then I say something
crazy, and I'm like,
well, I tried to ask,
but people-- you know?
So I'm in that space
of like I need--
like how do we help
people understand
this work a little better?
And that doesn't
actually always mean
that it has to be
a person, right?
There are some amazing texts
and things like that out there.
But I do think that it is some
people's real work to help
other people think about
the world a little deeper,
but it's not everybody's.
I think that, again,
it's like this either/or.
It's either like nobody's
work or it's everybody's
is how people often paint it.
As opposed to saying,
it might not be yours,
but it might be mine, which I
think is probably a little more
honest and real, while we make
sure that the people who think
that this is their work
always check their motivations
for being in the work.
AUDIENCE: You mentioned
you're a big fan of Twitter,
and Twitter has been a great
platform for a lot of people
to sort of be able
to have conversations
that they couldn't have before.
At the same time,
Twitter has also
come up in various
contexts and it
has an interaction
method that often
enables harassment and abuse.
And so I'm wondering
about your thoughts
on navigating the line
between both opening up
conversations but also opening
up vulnerable populations
in interactions.
DERAY MCKESSON: Yeah.
I think it's a good question.
You know, I've blocked 19,000
people personally on Twitter.
So I completely
get the harassment.
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER: Like individually?
DERAY MCKESSON: Individually.
One at a time.
And I did a screening of
the Panthers documentary
in Baltimore at The Charles,
this independent movie theater.
And people tweeted
in death threats.
The police came, they shut
down the movie theater.
So I get it, right?
I get their recipes.
And my Twitter account
got hacked the other day.
My phones got hacked
the other day.
Somebody called Verizon
impersonating me,
got the SIM number
changed, so my phone
was bricked for a little bit.
And then they used
2-Factor to hack
into my Gmail and
my Twitter account.
So I get the harassment piece.
There are a couple things.
One is I think that Twitter
just recently changed
the blocking feature.
You know, I know the
people at Twitter well.
I don't always know why they
make the decisions they do.
There's no blog post about
this change in blocking,
but I think it is a real change.
So when you block people
now, they are very blocked.
Whereas before, if somebody
blocks you and you block them,
there were like
these workarounds
that you could still interact
with them, essentially.
And now that is gone, and I
think that's a real thing.
The thing that people
talk about the most
is the sheer volume, right?
So you'll get people who flood
your-- if somebody targets you
on Twitter, and then all
of a sudden like 100 people
are tweeting you, it's a pretty
not fun experience, right?
I don't know what the
quick solution is for that.
I don't know.
As somebody who
gets it, I'll get
people who will put-- you
know, when I got hacked,
somebody spoofed these fake
DMs about me and Netta.
And they put them all
over the internet.
So for two days, my mentions
were like just people
upset about that.
Because the DMs
are like, you want
to put martial law in
the country or whatever.
So literally, it's
like hundreds of like,
why do you want martial law?
And I'm like, get
these out of here!
I don't know what
Twitter would have done.
I don't know what the solution
looks like in that space.
I do think Twitter is really
slow around the harassment
stuff.
So you submit a
thing saying you've
been harassed or whatever,
and it's like 10 hours later.
And they've got to
figure that out, right?
There's a volume issue there
I think is tough for them,
because people abuse
the report function too.
People will mass report somebody
they hate as being hacked,
and then they'll
freeze their account.
And they need to
figure that part out.
I think that they have not
figured out the speed part.
And when my Twitter
account got hacked,
it took me a while to get
back in, and I know them.
Right?
And the speed piece
I think is like what
actually-- which is what I worry
about more than anything else.
I do think it's
unique in the sense
that it's the most
open platform, right?
Facebook is your friends.
So when they say
something crazy,
you'll unfriend
them or something
and then maybe block
them or report them,
but it's different.
Twitter is like
standing on the corner
and it's like the world
is right there, right?
And there's this
question of like,
do you put up these [? cones ?]
so the world can't see you,
which fundamentally
changes what it
means to stand on the corner.
Or do you make sure that
people can't run you over?
It's like what are the
two pendulant swings?
And I think that Twitter
is still finding its space.
But I do think it
doesn't get credit
for how hard it is to keep the
commitment it has while making
sure that the platform is safe.
I do think that they've been
really slow on user names,
though.
You shouldn't be able
to have a name that's
like I hate the N word.
That doesn't make sense to me.
And they have been
slow on there.
I have no insider
knowledge about this,
but I think that they also have
not moved away from the rat
race around users, right?
They're in this user
race with Facebook.
And I think that Twitter's
real story is about impact,
and they have not figured out
a metric around impact yet.
And if they did, I think
that they would win.
Like they'd win that fight, but
they are still fighting people
around this user thing.
And you think about
yesterday with the sit-in.
And it's like, when Paul
Ryan cut off C-SPAN,
it was Periscope.
That was it.
It was an immediate-- like
this is an impact thing.
And they are still fighting
people in this user thing
that I think is a loss.
I think they will not
win the user fight.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
So my question is
about something
you were talking about
earlier, calling out
comments that people make.
This is something I
really want to do more.
And I think I'm kind of getting
better and better at doing it.
I think it's a lot
easier though, for me,
when it's in a context
when, you know,
I'm talking to
another white person,
or there are only
white people there.
Where it's been a lot
more difficult is,
there are people of
color in the group who
don't respond to the comment,
or even sometimes seem
to agree with it.
And I think where this has
come up for me in particular
is with older gay men in the
city, which a lot of people
will know that the gay
community in San Francisco does
tend to skew older.
So I've come across
older gay men of color
who don't seem to want to
respond to these comments.
And I don't know if it's because
this is like a way of survival,
having been in this community
for so long, that they
kind of-- I don't know.
I guess I'm wondering if
you have noticed anything
like that, if you have
any advice for how
to address the situation.
DERAY MCKESSON: Yeah.
Sometimes it is real that
people-- sometimes people
stay stuff around me that,
I should say something,
but I'm like, I'm
too tired today.
We're going to go
back and forth,
and I just can't do it today.
I think about the woman-- and
this woman worked on the Amtrak
train.
And she said something
crazy the other day.
And I just had to
tweet like, I'm not
going to let the devil get
me, because [INAUDIBLE].
So that is real.
So some people are
tired, and that's real.
Confrontation, though, the
word sounds harsher than it is.
I think there are simple things.
Like, "What did
you mean by that"
is totally a way to start
a conversation with people
that gets you on the
path of either holding
people accountable or
changing people's minds
but is a very simple entrance.
And I think with people that
you have seen not address things
that you think are sort of
problematic, I think there's
a way to say like, I thought
that was really troubling,
what did you think about that,
as a way to sort of get to the,
why didn't you say anything?
So that you can learn
a little better.
I do think that
people, unfortunately,
start to think about
confrontation as this like
you need to have a billboard
that's like, I can't believe
you let your community down,
which is a not helpful way
to think about this work.
But I think there
are simple ways
to create the entrance that
then allow you to build,
which is like, what
made you say that?
What did you mean by that?
I think those questions,
I've seen those be
super effective entry points.
And then you just need to be
thoughtful about continuing
that.
And that puts, again, the
onus on the other person.
Like you're not doing the work.
They're doing the hardest work.
You're doing the work
of asking the question.
AUDIENCE: I love the policy
proposals and the platform
on Campaign Zero.
It looks amazing, and I'm
really interested in seeing
how it can be brought in
the local and state level
and national level.
One thing I'm wondering about,
though-- particularly because
in San Francisco we've had
a huge increase in property
crimes recently.
There have been two stabbings
within a block of my apartment.
And I know that the
constituency in my neighborhood,
which is the Castro, which is
generally whiter, wealthier,
even if gay, would have--
like their instinct would
be to demand even more
enforcement of these loitering
laws and those kind of things.
And then at the same time,
I see from my parents living
in New Orleans, which has also
been going through a crime
wave, their instinct is
to have more police that
are intervening more.
So I guess what I want to know
is, from your perspective,
when you're having conversations
with people whose instinct is
driven by fear, and who
look to the police as a way
of assuaging that fear, and
you want to say to them,
hey, no, this is a
longer term solution,
and we need to actually get here
so that everyone feels safe,
how do you approach
that and what works?
DERAY MCKESSON:
People's proclivity
to call for the police
makes total sense to me.
In a world where
we have made people
believe that police
equals safety.
I get it, whether I
agree with it or not.
I think that when we think
about community violence--
if you think about
the legal economy,
there's a way to
deal with conflict.
If I don't like you,
I call your boss.
I file a lawsuit.
I file a complaint.
There's a whole apparatus.
In the illegal economy,
there's only one way
to deal with conflict,
and there's violence.
So if the solution to community
violence, all that stuff,
is not about getting people
out of the illegal economy,
I think we will always
spin our wheels.
Any solution that isn't about
like jobs, education, housing,
those are the actual solutions
that will change the needle.
In the absence of those,
the police, I think,
will always be
people's best solution.
So when you think about
Baltimore, 40% of adults
can't functionally read.
It's a crisis, right?
So we could bring
every industry we
want in America to Baltimore.
People can't read, not
going to matter, right?
It's going to matter
significantly less.
People are going to wake up
being like, I need money.
How do I get it?
And if that is selling drugs
or doing whatever, people are
going to get their needs met.
And again, I think the work
around getting people out
of the illegal economy is
like the not sexy, super dull
but like the work that actually
changes people's lives.
If you think about the
homeless populations,
it's like, we know that it
is better for homeless people
to be in homes than not,
which sounds really simple.
But there are people who
will see a homeless person
and will take them to
drug treatment first.
And we actually
know the outcomes
if you do that are worse
than if you actually
just put the person in a home.
And it's called the
"housing first" strategy
that people need homes before
they need anything else.
But it's easier to be like,
we're going to put you
in drug treatment for today!
And then you actually didn't
solve any of the problems.
So I don't know a great
response to people
who call the police like
that, because I get it.
I get why older people
do it specifically,
my grandmother
being one of them.
But I also believe
that the way to get out
of that is to really think
about community violence
in a completely different way
that is very structural, very
not sexy.
It's about jobs,
literacy, access,
those sort of things,
transportation, you know?
I know people in
Baltimore who can only
work in parts of the
city because that's
where the buses go, right?
So they physically cannot get
to another part of town in less
than three hours, and they're
not going to get a job.
They just won't.
They're not going to make
that choice, which severely
limits the opportunities they
have, which is a crazy thing.
That's real, though.
AUDIENCE: My question
is-- well, first of all,
we know that change is
not happening fast enough.
And you were talking about sort
of the stages of organizing
and how only the third
one, the third step,
is being able to see outcomes.
And that's obviously
not fast enough
because people's
lives are on the line.
And I'm just curious about how
you personally stay patient,
and how you stay sane, and how
you bear witness and organize
around all these things when
you put so much effort in
and things are
still so very slow?
DERAY MCKESSON: Yep.
So I know I'm not alone,
and that's important to me,
that I'm one of many people
who are doing this work.
I have great friends,
which is helpful.
And I was a teacher.
You know, I used to
teach sixth grade math,
and I feel a
responsibility to make sure
that those kids
live in a world that
is not the world I grew up in.
And that keeps me
hopeful, you know?
I'm like, I got
it, we can do it.
And all across the country, I've
seen people find their voices
and step up in ways that give me
incredible-- like if I had not
been in Ferguson,
I think I would not
be an organizer in
this way right now.
But I saw all these people who
never, ever would be together.
Like doctors, lawyers,
unemployed people, [INAUDIBLE].
We were all of one
community in a way
that all those other
labels didn't matter.
We were people
with shared values,
and that really changed me.
And that gives me
this immense hope.
And again it is, I
believe, two things--
there are more people that want
to do the work than know what
to do, and more people
that want to good work
than want to be members.
And, for me, there's
this huge challenge of,
how do we organize those people?
And I think we can do it.
I think tech will be a
part of how we do it.
I think we've been trying
to figure out slowly--
partly because people have
been dealing with the day
to day trauma, so they
haven't pulled back
to think about sort
of macro spaces.
But that keeps me
really hopeful.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: And along
with Andy and many,
many other medical students who
are part of this organization
called White Coats
for Black Lives.
And it focuses on
bringing attention
to structural racism and gun
violence and other issues that
are public health
issues but historically
haven't been thought of as so.
And my question is throughout
my year and a half or so
being involved with
this, I've come
across many people whose hearts
and minds are already one.
But because of the structure,
or because of things
they have on the line,
they don't have
on the line, they
don't feel motivated
to either effect change
or to join the movement.
And so I guess my
question is, how do you
get people to contribute more
once you've already convinced
them of what you're doing?
DERAY MCKESSON: Good question.
I met with the people who
run Doctors for America,
and I think they're
doing great work,
and I think y'all
are doing great work.
With the health care
thing, I think some of it
is messaging, too.
Like I think we should
talk about healthcare--
our health beyond hospitals.
That's a simpler way to
think about it, that health
is about so much more than
when you go to the doctor,
that health is a
broader thing, and we
need a public
conversation, and doctors
need to lead that conversation.
So that's one piece.
What do you do after you've
won hearts and minds?
Hearts and minds is hard to win,
so that's like you pat yourself
on the back for two seconds.
And then I think it's about
being as explicit as possible
about what the ask is.
Because I think that
sometimes we figure out,
we got this community,
we're like, people care.
And then we're like,
go do the work!
And people are like,
well what does that mean?
And they're like, the work.
And you're like, I
don't really know.
And I think that that
actually doesn't help.
I think that's how we lose
people really quickly,
is that they feel like
it's like a lot of hot air
when, in reality,
I think that making
the choice around what
the discrete thing to do
is actually really hard,
and organizers always
feel really pained.
Because there's a million
things that people should do.
So saying to people
like, here are the three
things we want you
to do right now
is something I've seen even
the most incredible organizers
really shy away from.
Because they're nervous
that they're forgetting
something or da, da, da.
But I think that that is
actually what keeps people.
Just like when I was
a teacher-- you know,
kids want to feel success.
They want to walk
into a building
and feel successful every day.
And so do adults.
Adults want to
feel like the thing
that they devoted their time
to is part of a success story.
And some of that we
have to be like-- we
have to be
manufacturing the sense
that we have to be really
thoughtful about it.
It's like when I give the
first test in-- when I taught,
first test, every kid
was going to pass it.
I wasn't giving
them the answers,
but it was like
just hard enough,
but we would do enough
prep right before
that I knew that you had
to sleep through the test
to fail it.
Everybody was going to
pass the first test.
Second test, super hard.
It was like all this
content that I needed
them to really, really grasp.
But I needed to set up a system
where they felt successful
when the challenges came.
And I think that
in organizing work,
we have to make sure that people
can experience success early,
or they know that they've
experienced success.
And then we offer things
that they can actually do.
So even when it might
be a loss, the success
is like, it's a new community,
and it's a new da, da, da.
That we are always thinking
about how we make people
feel like they're
doing something.
Because you know
as well as I know
there are a million things that
are competing with your time,
right?
You could be watching "Game of
Thrones"-- great last episode.
Or you could be
organizing, right?
And you want people to choose
the thing that you're doing.
But I do think it's
about how are you really
discrete with what the ask is.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: I was
interested in you
were talking about the
issues of homelessness
and earlier about
the issues dealing
with the police contracts.
And I found, in a
lot of cases, it
looks like theoretically there's
a program to help someone.
But when you really
dig into it, there's
so much paperwork and
so much unsexy barriers.
What can you do as
advocates to try
to get attention around those
issues and to deal with them?
Like, my uncle is pretty
much nonfunctional,
and it took six months
of constant work
from multiple relatives just
to get him basic Medicaid.
And they still have
to administer it.
There's no program to actually
give him the help he needs.
DERAY MCKESSON: Yeah.
I mean, I think this is where
tech people come in, too.
And this is why I
think it's important
that we do keep talking about
the problems, but not only
the problems, is that-- I
think that some people who have
incredible skill that can help
us organize differently just
don't know what parts
of the world look like.
And then it's like,
how do we help
people be exposed
to those experiences
so they can do something?
Like there's this great Twilio--
I know a lot about Twilio
all of a sudden.
But these people have
created this way--
so food stamps go
unclaimed in communities
all across the country.
And one of the
problems is people
don't want to go sit at the
Social Security building
and then type in [INAUDIBLE].
Who wants to do that all day?
So they've created
a text-based way
to figure out if you
qualify for food stamps.
So you text this number.
You fill out the whole
questionnaire on text.
It pops out at the end,
like you do qualify or not.
So by the time you
get to the office,
you already know,
yes or no, right?
Fascinating tech solution.
Totally simple.
I don't know anybody who
knows the number, right?
But it is a great solution.
And it's like how do we have
people build the solutions
and then put them out there?
When I was running for
mayor of Baltimore,
I did a visit to
Meals On Wheels.
Did you know the average
age of a volunteer
at Meals On Wheels in
Central Maryland is 70?
And I was like, which is
great for the 70-year-old.
Y'all need a new strategy
around volunteers, you know?
And I will bet
you that there are
people who would totally
deliver a meal every morning
before going to work.
They would do it, right?
But they need a different
way of thinking about how
people sign up and da, da, da.
They clearly don't-- they
just don't get it, right?
I think that there are people
in marketing who would totally
donate a couple hours
to help them come up
with a different
volunteer strategy.
And it's like,
how do we actually
put those sort of like cases
that are relatively simple,
but have a huge
impact on people--
how do we create
space where people
with different kinds of
skills can meet them?
So I don't have a
great answer, but I
do think that some
of this is helping
people think about
the problems and being
exposed to the problems.
I think the solutions, there's
enough good energy out there
that can deal with them.
And then there's
a responsibility
for people who have platforms
to really push them.
Like, I'm all about
this food stamp thing.
I saw it.
I was like everybody
should-- I mean,
only if you need food stamps.
But people should
totally know this number,
because it does
really good work.
It just isn't being-- people
don't know about it yet.
SPEAKER: Well, DeRay,
thank you so much for--
DERAY MCKESSON: Thank y'all.
I appreciate it.
SPEAKER: --coming and
educating and having
this dialogue with this.
Really appreciate it.
[APPLAUSE]